[Music]
this is not weird to you i mean they're
not weird they're the only people i've
ever heard of to smuggle drugs into
mexico i don't know baby
screw it what can we for once just in
our lives because they screw it to all
the plans and just get on the damn boat
don't read something to do this it's
cause i love you mm-hmm
it's because you're my fiancee now yeah
i'm saying yeah i like the sound of that
good to have you back
sunstroke is no joke so people stay
hydrated
with water the marshals are very strict
when it comes to alcohol wagering and
profanity
now we're on a championship course
so we are going to be keeping this club
pristine
so gabe uh
why don't you and bennett play with
marcus and ron today where's ryan anyway
got you six captain uh lieutenant good
to see you hope you're comfortable in
enforcement oh there's at least one girl
involved
what does this mean depress holy bear
it's a phrase that has special meaning
to people such as myself marcus
reminded a powerful weapon like this
should only be used when absolutely
necessary
now put that bottle on your head
i'm gonna shoot it off yes
no seriously stop playing it's fine we
play this game at home all the time babe
he's not serious we've been drinking it
we've been smoking
count it
what
you hit the bottle this time
oh my god
[Laughter]
oh there they are ladies and gentlemen
the bride and groom to be emily and
marcus
what the hell is that you son of a [ __ ]
you said we were best friends what are
you two doing here
excuse me this is a private event oh
it's cool we know the bride and groom we
met these two animals down in mexico
why does the salt not taste salty oh
because it's cocaine what i don't do
drugs even on vacation
okay look we just got a container
this only happened because you said see
you later i said it without meaning that
like any decent person would and somehow
he's charming my dad hope you're
comfortable and enforcing oh if there's
at least one girl involved
[Music]
this weekend is all about you well i
like the sound of that
we do too
good evening everyone what is he doing
marcus and i crossed paths in mexico get
to know each other intimately
this is the best wedding i've ever been
to
put that bottle on your head babe he's
not serious we've been drinking it
count it you hit the bottle this time
what
i'm john cena i'm little real i'm yvonne
orgy i'm meredith hagner let's get this
party started here we go
[Music]
i'm nervous sometimes in life we have to
make huge decisions like margarita or
beer can i get some tequila question why
does the salt not taste salty oh because
it's cocaine what get a little crazy
splurge we're gonna go on vacation might
as well go all out right and go bro
swim chunks of speedo the people want to
know
depends on the occasion
early bird or night owl early bird night
out
i'm going kyla all the way she seems a
bit out there yo you're not gonna step
in and help her or him
neither
count it oh my god you hit the bottle
this time
stream vacation friends
rated r only on hulu august 27th
[Music]
you